[Music]
Taylor Lautner's wife Taylor Dome poking
fun at her hubby it's unbelievable Dome
shared this Tick Tock writing when
you're not the only tailor he dated
[Music]
it's just a lot of alive yeah Dome is
referencing Lautner's brief relationship
with X Taylor Swift
me
hey I'm Taylor I'm Taylor yeah it's
confusing yeah we know that
remember when the two played a young
couple in 2009's Valentine's Day oh my
gosh I totally love him and I'm crazy
about her it was a good time it was a it
was a fun fun few months there Taylor
has a history of dating his co-stars I
don't know seems Lautner's current lady
loves also saying I remember it all too
well don't myself declared Swifty posted
the tick tock in honor of the singer's
eras tour starting this week
[Music]
I'm like an OG T Swift fan though oh gee
yeah there's no bad blood between the
two as Dome gushed over Swift during an
appearance on the vile files podcast
earlier this year like I was trying to
find this don't you you have like a
photo with her when you're like I was
nine years old or something when she I
went to one of her first concerts like
ever it was at the tiniest theater my
best friend like loved her and then I
did too and even tried shooting her shot
to score tickets to Swift's upcoming
highly demanded shows I hope we can go
Taylor if you're hearing this can we
come yeah I'll see if we can get us
something I would like to go take your
master didn't crash
foreign